so to put things in context
is that
uh yeah it was an element of a test but
it was really more of a prank and it was
a continuating prank that she actually
started he snaps his head bougie so i
put him in the hood y'all context is
everything because that just changes the
entire conversation now instead of
bringing her to the home where we're
gonna live at i'm gonna bring her to my
childhood home we are
home
before we get into
this test that was a huge conversation
for the 90 day fans i know before we get
into that i'm curious you two are 90 day
newbies whose idea was it for you to
join the show
yeah yeah i surprised you
he didn't wanted anything to do with a
reality show he was like you know i'm a
private person i don't want to put
myself out there i was like you know
what i've always lived inside of the box
i want to do something different and i
kind of begged him basically to
be on it with me
yeah
how do you feel about that decision now
below
just like putting our whole life in
front of everybody i was pretty
i was like nah we're not doing that
but um
she she tends to get her way so
um like most things so i i submit it and
here we are yeah so have you been
watching the episodes back
we have like we i've been watching it
how do you feel
like for me it's strange watching
yourself on television i laughed so hard
with my facial expressions i had no idea
i made so much faces i was like oh my
god is that me
yeah
i am definitely a treaty woman we always
express ourselves by our face well shy
you slinged into bellows dms that's how
you two first met
what was it about him that made you say
okay i'm gonna shoot my shot okay i'm i
was looking for someone like who is
mature first of all someone who's
responsible someone who's ambitious and
someone who's a a good father like a
father you know he has kids and i
observe these qualities with him just by
judging his online pictures and also
i was attracted to him you know i was
like okay he takes good care of his body
he looks well put together type of
gentleman so you know i shook my
shoulder slot into his dms because we
used to
um converse back and forth like you know
he would make a little comment on my
pictures and say great job when i'm
doing some promotions with my yoga
business so he was attracted to how i
was you know
into my business you see an ambitious
woman and i was also attracted because
you know he was like a gentleman-like
type of guy
i spent seven days in trinidad so we
only spent actually seven days together
physically uh before we decided that
okay this is official well bilal you
decided to propose after seven days of
being with shy in person and she's
beautiful of course but beyond that what
was it that made you say okay this is
going to be my wife i had a chance to
meet her and her her mother and her
stepfather really the whole family
everybody's there so everybody's
grilling me and we're having a great
time
and um i don't know i just felt that she
had the essence of things that i was
looking for when it comes to
great motherly qualities
for my children and any future children
to come you know she was um she wears
her faith on her sleeve you know she's
very guide conscious
so a lot of different traits that i was
looking for she uh possessed so i wanted
to see if sheida truly wants me for me
not for what i have you know she told me
she either ride or die so let's put that
to the test blouse some people felt as
if
it wasn't right for you to test shy by
picking her up in a van that wasn't
yours taking her to your childhood home
acting as if you lived there some even
felt as if you were gaslighting her
so looking back now do you regret the
prank
you know um
i definitely would say i would probably
do some things differently for sure
i don't know how long we have but just
to put things in context we're good talk
okay okay she said talk so to put things
in context
is that
uh yeah it was an element of a test but
it was really more of a prank and it was
a continuating prank that she actually
started
so
when i went to trinidad
um i um
you know i let her know i said hey
here's some airbnbs that i could stay at
you know you choose which one should i
stay at because i'm not married with the
area she said okay yeah sure so she
picked the one for me to stand and lo
and behold
the airbnb
was in
the middle of the the worst crime area
ever
right so i'm staying at this airbnb and
i don't really don't know i know it's
kind of you know suspect when i'm
walking around she's like she's calling
me a night like where are you at i'm
like oh she's like no you need to go
back to your you know like so i don't
even know like the area is
i can that bad
it looks bad and then her mother
she picked us up and she was like
shout out why do you have him staying in
such a such area what was it was the
area called it was carnage
so
and it was a bad area so like literally
it was like i was in
an institution
there was like barbed wire fencing
around the premise it was a bad area so
she thought it was very funny
you have this man looking the way he
does in that area
so i put him in the hood
i am what you would call
hood
boujee with a little bit of booziness
because it was fantastic
it was
fences time you let me know i'm heard
because that's bywire
boujee so i was like okay i'm gonna put
him in somewhere affordable hun
it still was bougie because it was like
barbed wire all around so he was
protected in his boujee airbnb
so hilarious yeah so we both like to
joke humor so
in the back i'm like okay
good one you know i was there for seven
days
not one but seven i was like you know
what i'm gonna pay you back you know i'm
gonna get you back so she forgot i was
like you're not gonna know where it's
gonna come from then with the house i
was like
i just really wanted to surprise her
because she would send me a lot of you
know
pictures of like oh this is like my you
know home that i would like to live in
will we you know do do well in life etc
and i'm thinking to myself like
the house looks kind of like the house i
live in already so you know so i'm like
maybe i just want to surprise her when
she comes
and then the idea came like oh i
remember she pranked me i'm gonna get
her back and one day we were actually
watching because we were watching movies
together from a long distance like
netflix like press play press play at
the same time
watching one of our favorite movies
coming to america and i was like
i know what i'm gonna do i know i'm
going to do
so
that was that was it y'all context is
everything because that just changes the
entire conversation
yeah in my opinion um
have you ever had instances where women
did just want you for money have you
ever ran into that
no i i really haven't i mean i've um
you know you hear things about people
like oh you know um
they're you know just in it for the
money or this this and that like i've
never been
um
you know
i'm really this funny thing is i've
never really been flashy you know you
might see me on social media with a suit
on that's because that's just what i do
for a living and you're losing
your lubricants your louboutin yeah you
know um so but like if you don't like
you never see me taking a picture next
to my cars or taking a picture you know
what personal homes or anything like
that like only homes that you see are
things that i'm like selling for clients
so i never been like flashy that way or
anything like that and if you i mean if
you know it if you're into brands so you
may know something subtle like oh he
wears this belt or his accent etc yeah
but
i never really had the experience of
somebody just wanting you for like
something that you have yeah i'm putting
shy to the test a little bit wow home
sweet home right when shiny comes in
today i'm gonna bring her to my
childhood home the home that i actually
grew up in just to see that if i did
live here will you still be with me
you said this was a prank but in the
show you did say you wanted to test
chyda to see if she really wanted you
for who you are or what you have so that
being said what do you say to people who
feel as if you do these type of tests
before you decide to make someone your
wife
yeah you know like i can admit that
there was really three elements by far
the most of it was a prank but there was
some elements of the test and i think
with any joke there is like some truth
in it so what to see like you know
because she would say things may come
like hey like a minute to win it and i
would ask her things like let's say for
some reason let's say if i had money and
for some reason i lost it all like would
you would you ride with me would you
help me build it back up she's like for
sure no doubt so everybody says that but
then when you put into that moment you
know so it's like well
so yeah there were some elements of a
test um and frankly also there was a lot
of settlement elements to it as well too
um the truck it wasn't just any truck it
was actually um my father's truck
and it was one of his trucks and he he
uh he recently passed
and he didn't get a chance to meet chida
physically they spoke of the phone and
video et cetera and
the home was a house that not just my
childhood but i grew up there like 20
plus my years of my life
and
um my father actually helped built that
house
so
it was it was really sentimental to say
hey like this is it was a way of like
really introducing her to my father
before i introduced her to the rest of
my family because i really feel him
there
and
um but also to show her too like these
are my roots and to really know me no no
this is where i came from yeah knowing
that about the van chada do you regret
the whole sanford and sun i call it i
totally regret this something i'm trying
to comment
this place looking like something on sun
when you spin a test on me i am totally
unaware so i'm thinking it's just some
his truck his personal belongings so i'm
not thinking it has any sentimental
value right so my exclamation was just
natural you know something and sonia
picked him up
yeah she was killing me with the
comments and then with the house it was
so i mean it started as a prank and then
it started to become like oh man like
you taking shots no she has she look
shady you can you give shade you are
good with the shades you're just coming
back to back i'm like she's quick with
her tongue yes so quick she'd be killing
me i was so upset i was so angry man
that's feeling
yeah i gotta get that done it looks like
it could collapse on us any moment
though
i was trying to hold back a lot of
anger at him you know because he met me
i'm a woman with standards yeah you have
standard doesn't mean you have to be
rich or look serious you have you could
be clean you know coming in coming out
of the truck see it though the first
thing my eye went up there to see that
ceiling window oh the big hole in it
that's the first thing i saw when i came
home yeah i want the house yeah on the
house i saw the window with a wall and
after i saw the little edges peeling
apart the paints you know the veranda
the porches falling down i was like
stuff just because it's it's it's a it's
a humble home doesn't mean it has to be
look at this that's true that was my
that was my heartbeat believe it or not
actually
like
i spent like the whole weekend like
cleaning up that house like it was
really in because it was this area where
my father would store a lot of his stuff
there in it
for 15 plus years so
cleaned it up a lot you know so what you
see actually on tv was like hours and
hours of like brother sister helping
well you flip houses though too right
have you ever thought about flipping
that house for sure it definitely did my
father um like i said he recently passed
however my father too he um
he's a type person like he wants to do
it himself
you know so he had rental properties as
well too and
um so anytime something was to fix he
would do it himself and so he didn't
want anybody touching his house
houses or anything like that so it's not
necessarily a house that i also out of
respect no i you know didn't do anything
to it that makes sense i saw that in the
comments you know 90 day fans are really
creative with the way they think about
all of these things and someone was like
why didn't he just flip the house if he
flips houses i was like that's kind of
that's a good question my dad would kill
me if i touch this house
okay well let's get into how you reacted
to the prank shita do you regret
anything
you said um you mentioned something
about do you have enough money for that
when he asked you did you want food you
want something to eat
yeah something that's from a clean bowl
yeah
yeah well i can order something
i know you don't want to eat you have
enough money for that
that was harsh i felt i i i regret that
pot you know like you know they're
telling him do you have enough money for
that it was it was insultive towards him
i was so upset like i was like you want
to buy me food but he can't even take
care of her home because first of all
i'm thinking if you can't maintain your
home what makes you think that you could
maintain me you know i give up my life i
close on my yoga business i made this
huge um move to america with a little
bit of savings in my pocket you know but
at the same time i'm depending on him
because i can't work so i'm looking at
him as my
my my main source of income so now it's
like you're offering me food to eat i
was like take the money for food and fix
the house you know so i was like you
have enough money for that yeah
i should not have said that to you i
wish she would not have tested me
because i was holding back so much
things i wanted to see and i felt like
this could have destroyed us like i was
really trying to bite my tongue
so you know take care if i'd lose my
cool and he would have kept me there for
a longer time what would have happened
to us you know that little bit that i
said
we still have arguments based on that
like he still
yes we have been going past this test it
still comes up you still talk about it
and and see how much i have hurt his
feelings and i tried to express my point
of view so i was thinking you test me on
something that really could have you
know i felt like it was just too heavy
this is where you'll be staying at oh my
god
when you walk into velal's house and he
says this is your new home this is where
you're about to live describes us the
feeling that you felt
i was like no this is home this is what
i expect
this is what i left my business and my
family to you know to come to
like this is this is what i call a house
you know it was comfortable you know
everything looking around nice and
polished my type of style you know this
is what i wanted and this is what i was
expecting yeah how have you been dealing
with bilal's ocd because according to
your ex-wife you are very particular if
she leaves the socks on the floor
there's gonna be some issues she gonna
be out she might have to sleep on the
couch bellow's very picky
and
i wish some luck he drives me insane
yeah he is very so particularly so neat
his luggage he packs his pools like a
cycle you know when i pack until i put
my things you know i don't know how he
gets like 25 pieces of clothes and one
luggage because he packed it so neat and
small i mean my dad was in the military
so you know so us having a standard of
like cleaning and be and i wouldn't even
say i would actually
um i would not say i'm ocd uh because
i've been told differently that
it actually isn't the best term to use
um
just from a standpoint of of people who
actually have that so
you know i apologize for actually using
the term um i would say i'm a neat freak
you know like i you know i definitely
like things to be clean and neat and
you know and be in a certain way
i'm cooking he's wiping when i'm cooking
he's like
no she's the messiest cooker i've ever
seen before in
even her mother says like
shy you can clean and cook as you go so
that way you don't have this huge
like disarray of mess when you're done
like did you never just step out and
just let her finish thank you he wants
to do a little shining and wiping and
i'm uncomfortable like the luck and i
cook in peace
i got a little something else to show
you
oh my god
oh my god
i will say the yoga studio
that
that was so touching
that was a great
thank you
see those things is isn't something like
that's the reaction is what i was
looking for in person like you can't get
that if i was just to show you
her if i would have showed her that on
yeah picture or video etc so that's why
i was holding certain things it wasn't
to be malicious it wasn't to be like
disingenuous to be dishonest it was just
show you like hey i want to surprise you
my whole perspective on youtube as a
couple i mean other than aesthetically
you you seem great together but now my
opinion has changed so this conversation
in general i'm sure it's going to change
a lot of people's um thoughts
yeah we'll
yeah
cross figures i have a fan question
which i feel like is going to answer a
lot
there are rumors circulating that you
two are married i know you can't say
anything when it comes to that but the
american wants to know below
how are you feeling about shaida at this
point is she currently wife material or
are you still having second thoughts i
would say she's she's a person who has a
strong
value a person who is definitely
somebody who
if i didn't somebody would definitely
wipe her up quick so
good answer yeah 90 day fiance fans are
very opinionated which i'm sure you have
experienced already
yeah how are you dealing with that
mentally like how has it been for you
well for me i've always put myself out
there in a back home they know me as a
yoga girl you know i've made newspapers
several times so i've always put myself
out here so it's nothing much for me to
deal with for him however he has never
put himself out there so
i've seen him you know i think some of
the comments were so harsh and
some of them are very distasteful so
i've seen he had a very difficult time
yeah i've gotten
phone calls i've gotten like emails i've
gotten uh
the like the the stuff that
people say is like wow and for me like i
i've been a person who has really i
guess
pretty much all my life to try to stay
a certain way and being you know
disrespectful towards people and good
heart you know i'm an imam which is you
know a person who is a um a leader in
our in our religious uh congregation
to you know do a lot of philanthropy and
a lot of just financial education and
giving back to
uh people that travel all around the
country doing that stuff so
um to get some of the back there's like
i've never experienced that before in my
life and it was just like it was just
eye-opening to see that
wow like
somebody can take like 10 20 minutes of
what they see
and
just
rip inform your opinion about you like
that it's like wow and i mean you could
dig you could see you know the works
that i've done you know if you really
truly want to look it for those things
but
um so that was kind of hurtful but on a
positive note you also see the beauty
you know and you see there's so much
more positive people that are out there
that you know are rooting for you
rooting for her especially for her
[Laughter]
so
she had a lot of support well i'm
curious you know speaking of the whole
god-consciousness of it all how do you
feel like this is growing you you know
is this expanding you in ways that you
didn't really know
you know having to figure out how to
deal with all these opinions it has it
has it's so funny because we talk you
know sometimes about like
you know because you know she can see
sometimes i'll get down or whatever and
i'm a very positive person and i think
you're going to see that as you see on
the show and i'm all about appreciation
being grateful and this this and that
and
um
but you know sometimes you know things
get to you and
you'll be like hey like you remember
pray for this you know and the reality
is that we didn't we we decided not to
we decided to move forward because we
felt that god was answering the prayers
for us to align us this way like we
wouldn't have even done this and we felt
anything different so i just had to keep
that perspective like you know that this
is it's just a test you know and
you know i always say for every level
there's another devil so at the end of
the day you know you just got to keep
moving forward and you know who you are
right more than any of us do
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay last question
what do you want fans to know about your
relationship if there's one thing you
want them to know before we get knee
deep into the season because we're still
at the beginning i just want fans to
know that our relationship is a real
relationship
if you put a camera in everyone's
relationship they're going to see
movements when they disagree when they
argue when they're in love it's a real
relationship you know i didn't put i'm
not putting on a facade because oh i'm
wearing a hijab i'm sure you knew that
yes i'm a muslim woman he's a muslim man
but we are real you know we have
problems like everyone else someone fans
that know that it's real a lot of people
thinking this test is fake and i have i
i know about the house it's the holy
month of ramadan i'm telling you i had
no idea about this house it was it was
my first reaction is how it played off
on television so i just want fans to
know that this is a real relationship
that they're getting to see on camera
[Music]